Hello, podcast listener. This is Smart List. I am Jason. I have a friend named Will and a friend named Sean. We, uh, we ask people questions, uh, if that's what you're looking for, you're in the right spot. I mean, like the energy is just, it's really love. The pluribus, honestly, I, I, that, you do with that, you know, here's your attitude. You're like, if you wanted to win and then if you, I just don't feel sincere. If I like, come on with a bunch of energy. Hey, listener, welcome to smart. Like we're not selling that. That's great. What you just did. That is great. Try more and sincere more often. I think people appreciate the non bullshit on this podcast.
你好，播客听众。这里是Smart List。我是Jason。我有两个朋友，一个叫Will，一个叫Sean。我们，呃，我们问人们问题，呃，如果你在找这个，那你来对地方了。我的意思是，那种能量，真的，那是爱。多元，老实说，我，我，那个，你用那个，你知道，这是你的态度。你就像，如果你想赢，然后如果你，我只是觉得不真诚。如果我，带着一堆能量进来。嘿，听众，欢迎来到smart。就像我们不是在卖那个。那太棒了。你刚才做的。那太棒了。多尝试，多真诚一点。我想人们会欣赏这个播客里的不废话。
People appreciate you when you're depressed. Is that what you're saying? It's free. Just deal with my mood today. It's an all new smart list. Let's go. Oh, look at haircut. Jesus. What wills? I think it's just slicked back. What's up haircut? I did not get my haircut. Congratulations. It'll grow back. Don't worry. I did not get my haircut. I just combed it. Huh. Hey, let me ask you something. When you guys go, cause I know you guys go for walks like I do, just to get some fresh air and walk during this crisis, this virus we're doing. But whenever I pass somebody on the sidewalk, I passed them and my conversation in my head is, okay, did I inhale like their
人们在你沮丧时会欣赏你。你是这个意思吗？它是免费的。今天就处理我的情绪吧。这是一个全新的smart list。我们开始吧。哦，看发型。天哪。什么Will？我想只是向后梳了。怎么了发型？我没剪头发。恭喜。它会长回来的。别担心。我没剪头发。我只是梳了一下。哈。嘿，让我问你一件事。当你们去，因为我知道你们像我一样去散步，只是为了呼吸新鲜空气，在这个危机，这个病毒期间走走。但每当我在人行道上经过某人时，我经过他们，我脑子里的对话是，好吧，我吸入了像他们
air? Even though there's masks behind it, did they inhale my air? I had that in the first, the first month of COVID when I'd walk by, I would, I would quietly either hold my breath or, or, or, or quietly just slowly exhale. Yeah. I still do it. Okay. Well, hang on. I got to admit something. And this is a true story when I pass strangers, four years have been holding my breath. Really? Yeah. Even without a mask. That's germy like me. You, you're not germy like me. Well, I'm quietly, I'm a, I'm a closet. Closet. Yeah. Yeah. Wow.
空气吗？即使后面有口罩，他们吸入我的空气了吗？我在COVID的第一个月就有过那种感觉，当我走过时，我会，我会悄悄地屏住呼吸，或者，或者，或者悄悄地慢慢呼气。是的。我仍然这样做。好吧。嗯，等等。我得承认一件事。这是一个真实的故事，当我经过陌生人时，四年来我一直屏住呼吸。真的吗？是的。即使没有口罩。那像我一样有细菌。你，你不像我一样有细菌。嗯，我悄悄地，我是个，我是个秘密的。秘密的。是的。是的。哇。
Are you really? Are you a handshaker normally? Yeah. I mean, I, yeah, but I just, I'm, I don't know, like, and then I lived in New York, I lived in New York for over 20 years, full time and use the subway was my main mode of transport, but I would do a lot of like, you know, So if you, when like speaking of the subway, when you walk by and you walk into like basically like a urine cloud, do you feel like you're getting some sort of a disease just because, well, I've smelt it. So therefore I have inhaled urine. I think about that all the time. Aerosol. All the time.
你是真的吗？你通常会握手吗？是的。我的意思是，我，是的，但我只是，我，我不知道，就像，然后我住在纽约，我在纽约住了20多年，全职，坐地铁是我主要的交通方式，但我会做很多像，你知道，所以如果你，当像说到地铁，当你走过，当你走进像基本上像一团尿云，你觉得你得了某种疾病，仅仅因为，嗯，我闻到了。所以我吸入了尿液。我一直都在想那个。气溶胶。一直都在想。
And now I'm going to have a bladder infection. Is that what you think, Will? I used to think like if you peed in a public urinal that he could travel through your stream up into your penis from the previous. Well, that part is true. That's part is true. Oh, that part is true. That part is true. So then I do have, that's where I got my STDs. Yeah. Boy, I did not know this about you, Will. But here's what you need, Sean, you know what it's like when you go up for dinner with Jason. So this is how it goes for just for our listener. When you go for dinner with Jason, you go into the restaurant, right? And so what he does is he takes the menu and he goes, okay,
现在我要得膀胱感染了。Will，你是这么想的吗？我过去常想，如果你在公共小便池小便，它可以通过你的尿流进入你的阴茎，从之前的。嗯，那部分是真的。那部分是真的。哦，那部分是真的。那部分是真的。所以我确实有，那就是我得性病的地方。是的。天哪，我不知道你这一点，Will。但这是你需要知道的，Sean，你知道和Jason一起吃晚饭是什么感觉。所以这就是我们的听众的情况。当你和Jason一起去吃晚饭时，你走进餐厅，对吧？所以他做的是他拿起菜单，然后说，好吧，
great. And he can't do anything. He says, great, let's just get an order in because what he has to do is get the order in. Then he pushes back from the table. He walks gingerly to the men's room and he washes his hands like he's going into surgery. And then he comes out with his hands in the air. No, they're down around the waist because I don't want to embarrass myself. They're like a surgeon and he comes in and then if, and I got to kick the chair. Yeah. She can't, if somebody comes late to the table and he's already been through that process, they're not getting a handshake, right, Jay? Before I start over, you got to do the whole, but I definitely wash my hands after I have,
太棒了。他什么也做不了。他说，太棒了，我们点餐吧，因为他必须做的是点餐。然后他从桌子旁推开。他小心翼翼地走到男洗手间，他洗手就像要去做手术一样。然后他出来时双手举在空中。不，它们在腰部周围，因为我不想让自己尴尬。它们像外科医生一样，然后他进来，然后如果，我得踢椅子。是的。她不能，如果有人晚到桌子，而他已经经历了那个过程，他们得不到握手，对吧，Jay？在我重新开始之前，你得做整个，但我绝对在我有之后洗手，
I've touched the menu. I've shook hands at the table, whatever that nonsense is, but then it's now it's eat time. So I got to go. We're going to boil the hands. I come back. Interesting point. Interesting that, wow, the sitting down and shaking hands at the table and greeting other human beings to him is the nonsense at the table. To him, that's the nonsense. I'm there to eat. All right. Let's get on with it. Um, gang. Yeah. We don't get a lot of duos, but today we got a duo. No. Yep. They are responsible for some of the most complicated and original music going today. They are also extremely successful. Usually when people do complicated stuff, it's not that successful. They know how to
我摸了菜单。我在桌子上握了手，不管那是什么废话，但现在是吃饭时间了。所以我得走了。我们要煮手。我回来了。有趣的观点。有趣的是，哇，坐下来在桌子上握手并问候其他人对他来说是桌子上的废话。对他来说，那是废话。我是去吃饭的。好吧。我们继续吧。嗯，伙计们。是的。我们没有很多二人组，但今天我们有一个二人组。不。是的。他们负责当今一些最复杂和原创的音乐。他们也非常成功。通常当人们做复杂的事情时，它并不那么成功。他们知道如何
do both. Their work has brought them. Hold on. I go to a different part of my notes here. It's Simon and Garfunkel. It's brought them five Grammy Awards, two American Music Awards, two Guinness World Records, three MTV Video Music Awards, and the youngest to win all the four main Grammy categories, Best New Artist, Record of the Year, Song of the Year, Album of the Year in the same year. Recently. Yeah, man. And I know it is. I think I know it is. You don't have to take your tone up. Well, I'm all fired up about this. They also happen to really love each other because their brother and sister, everybody, it's Billie Eilish O'Connell and Finneas Baird O'Connell. What? There they are. Hi, boys. No way. Hi, guys. Hi. This
做这两件事。他们的工作带给他们。等等。我去看我笔记里的不同部分。是Simon and Garfunkel。它带给他们五项格莱美奖，两项全美音乐奖，两项吉尼斯世界纪录，三项MTV音乐录影带大奖，并且是同时获得所有四个主要格莱美类别，最佳新人，年度唱片，年度歌曲，年度专辑的最年轻的人。最近。是的，伙计。我知道是。我想我知道是。你不必提高你的语调。嗯，我对这个很兴奋。他们也恰好真的很爱对方，因为他们是兄妹，大家，是Billie Eilish O'Connell和Finneas Baird O'Connell。什么？他们在那儿。嗨，男孩们。没门。嗨，伙计们。嗨。这
is, I mean, I might have to, guys, I might have to get the kids in here. They're going to go. Guess what? Well, look at me. Panning left. There's my kid. Oh my God. Yeah. Maple wanted to say hello. Now, Billie, you've worked with Maple before. You guys did a little guest spot on our friend, the talk show host, Mr. Jimmy Kimmel. You interviewed, she did the Lord's Prayer in Spanish. You remember this? Oh. Oh my God. Hi, Maple. All right. That's the end of that part. We got to get to business, mates. All right, you guys. Hi. Thank you very much for being on our podcast. Look at you both there. First of all, it's amazing to meet both of you. I am a huge fan. I remember, oh my God, and I'm freaking out
是，我的意思是，我可能不得不，伙计们，我可能得把孩子们带进来。他们会去。猜猜怎么着？嗯，看着我。向左平移。那是我的孩子。哦，天哪。是的。Maple想打个招呼。现在，Billie，你以前和Maple合作过。你们在我们朋友，脱口秀主持人，Jimmy Kimmel先生那里做了一个小客串。你采访，她用西班牙语做了主祷文。你记得这个吗？哦。哦，天哪。嗨，Maple。好吧。那部分结束了。我们得谈正事了，伙计们。好吧，你们。嗨。非常感谢你们参加我们的播客。看看你们俩在那里。首先，见到你们俩真是太棒了。我是个超级粉丝。我记得，哦，天哪，我吓坏了
because I'm nervous. Ocean, ocean. Ocean eyes. Ocean eyes. My God son played it for me on Spotify and I freaked out. I was like, but I have to say, you know, there's so, there's a lot of music out there, a lot of pop music and a lot of it is like fantastic. A lot of it isn't. But when I first heard your music, I was completely blown away. I mean, you and your brother, not since the carpenters, by the way, but I thought that what a way to pivot and not do what everyone else is doing. I mean, it was just so different and so powerful and you want to, do you guys want to hear us talk? Yeah, I was just going to say, listener, we swear they're here.
因为我很紧张。海洋，海洋。海洋之眼。海洋之眼。我的教子在Spotify上给我放了它，我吓坏了。我当时想，但我必须说，你知道，有很多音乐，很多流行音乐，很多都很棒。很多不是。但当我第一次听到你们的音乐时，我完全被震撼了。我的意思是，你和你的哥哥，顺便说一句，自从木匠乐队以来，但我认为这是一种多么好的转变方式，而不是做别人正在做的事情。我的意思是，它太不同了，太强大了，你想，你们想听我们说话吗？是的，我正要说，听众，我们发誓他们在这里。
That is such a fair question, but I have a question. I have a question. It was the opposite of the same stuff that's been coming out. So what made you guys like trust yourselves as artists that believe that there's an audience that would want something other than those kind of manufactured pop songs that they so crave, you know what I mean? Because it's so different. First of all, jokes aside, this is a very, very sweet question. So thank you very much. Yeah. I'm going to let you go.
这是一个非常公平的问题，但我有一个问题。我有一个问题。它与一直出来的那些东西正好相反。那么是什么让你们作为艺术家相信，有一个观众会想要除了那些他们如此渴望的制造出来的流行歌曲之外的东西，你知道我的意思吗？因为它太不同了。首先，开个玩笑，这是一个非常，非常甜蜜的问题。所以非常感谢。是的。我要让你走。
No, no, you keep going. You want me to take it? Yeah, you keep going. Well, to answer a really sort of like kind question, I think that the main thing is we just wanted to make music together and that was kind of our only big idea. So anything beyond that in terms of like what people it has reached or things that, you know, like compliments people have imbued it with, like, you know, to us, the success was just sitting down to write a song and actually writing one and then trying to record it and that
不，不，你继续。你想让我接手吗？是的，你继续。嗯，回答一个非常友善的问题，我认为最主要的是我们只是想一起做音乐，那是我们唯一的宏大想法。所以除此之外的任何事情，就它触及了什么，或者人们，你知道，像人们赋予它的赞美，就像，你知道，对我们来说，成功只是坐下来写一首歌，实际上写了一首，然后试着录制它，然后
going pretty well. So, you know, I think we've, we've kept our sort of like sites pretty low from the beginning in terms of like, let's just do something and try to make it not suck. Yeah, exactly. That's, Jason can relate to that. He's kept the bar low for so long. That's the key. You never pull a muscle if the bar is nice and low. And as I also say, also never build your high horse too close to the ground. You know what I mean? Because you're going to fall off at some point. If you could, you know, we're
进行得相当顺利。所以，你知道，我认为我们从一开始就保持了我们的视野相当低，就比如，让我们做点什么，试着让它不烂。是的，完全正确。那是，Jason可以对此产生共鸣。他把标准放得很低很久了。那是关键。如果标准很好且很低，你永远不会拉伤肌肉。正如我也说的，也永远不要把你的高头大马建得离地面太近。你知道我的意思吗？因为你迟早会掉下来的。如果你能，你知道，我们
in 2021 now, the last what three, four years have been, your head has spun around a few times and probably felt like it was going to come off. Right? It's just, you guys have been in writing this incredible wave and we asked this. I remember we had Paul McCartney on the show. We're kind of asking him the same thing, which is like, do you have those moments where you go, where you check in and you kind of look at each other and go, holy shit. Yeah. Does that ever happen or no?
现在是2021年了，过去的三，四年，你的头转了几圈，可能感觉它要掉下来了。对吧？只是，你们一直在驾驭这股不可思议的浪潮，我们问这个。我记得我们有Paul McCartney在节目上。我们有点问他同样的事情，就是，你有那些时刻，你去，你去检查，你有点看着对方说，天哪。是的。那会发生吗，还是没有？
It happens all the time, all the time, all the time. I mean, you know, in the bath a lot, you know what I'm saying? Separately. Or when I wake up. Yeah. When I wake up. Yeah. We don't take baths together.
它一直发生，一直，一直。我的意思是，你知道，在浴缸里很多，你知道我在说什么吗？分开。或者当我醒来时。是的。当我醒来时。是的。我们不一起洗澡。
No, God no. But every day, I mean, multiple times a day when I'm doing random stuff, when I'm, when I'm not, you know, it's very weird to think about. That's an interesting thing to me because, you know, in order to handle success, I would imagine you need to somehow put yourself in a place where you are not entitled or deserving of it, but that it's appropriate so that you don't have a panic attack when you're out in front of thousands and thousands of people. Yes. Yet it sounds like you're maintaining a keen sense of normalcy. So then how can those two
不，天哪，不。但每一天，我的意思是每天多次，当我做随机的事情时，当我，当我不是，你知道，想到这个很奇怪。对我来说这是一件有趣的事情，因为，你知道，为了处理成功，我想象你需要以某种方式把自己放在一个你并不理所当然或应得的地方，但它是合适的，这样当你站在成千上万的人面前时，你不会恐慌发作。是的。然而听起来你保持着一种敏锐的正常感。那么那两件事怎么能
things coexist? Like the normal person would get out on stage and go, oh my God, this is, I'm having a panic attack. You know, like how do you compartmentalize? How do you switch between the two? I mean, it's really weird because, you know, I have a job that basically a lot of it is just people complimenting me up my ass. You know what I mean? Where, you know. I know how it is. I know. Oh, whatever. No, but what I mean is that I have a job and a career that is like constantly, you know,
共存呢？就像正常人会走上舞台说，哦，天哪，这是，我正在恐慌发作。你知道，就像你怎么划分？你怎么在两者之间切换？我的意思是，这真的很奇怪，因为，你知道，我有一份工作，基本上很多只是人们在拍我的马屁。你知道我的意思吗？在那里，你知道。我知道是什么感觉。我知道。哦，随便。不，但我的意思是，我有一份工作和职业，就像不断地，你知道，
people saying I'm great or whatever. And it's really hard to, to not let that make you go, wow, I really am great. And then be horrible forever and just be completely self-righteous and, you know, whatever, because constantly it's just people putting you on this pedestal that no person should be on really. But then, you know, there's the other side of completely the opposite of that of people just, you know, hating your guts. But it's weird. What really humbles both of you guys? Like what are you both terrible at that keeps you, you remember the fact that you're not a superhero, you're just human and you suck at X, Y and Z. What's X, Y and Z?
人们说我很棒什么的。而且真的很难，不让那让你去，哇，我真的很棒。然后永远变得可怕，只是完全自以为是，你知道，随便，因为不断地只是人们把你放在这个没有人应该真正站在的基座上。但然后，你知道，有完全相反的一面，人们只是，你知道，讨厌你的胆量。但很奇怪。什么真正让你们俩谦虚？就像你们俩在什么方面很糟糕，这让你们，你记得你不是超级英雄的事实，你只是人类，你在X，Y和Z方面很烂。X，Y和Z是什么？
Can you, are you guys terrible at cooking? Like not boil water? We can cook. I'm terrible at that. Yeah, you are. Yeah. Boiling water. Yeah. It's tough.
你们，你们在烹饪方面很糟糕吗？就像不能烧开水？我们可以做饭。我在那方面很糟糕。是的，你是。是的。烧开水。是的。很难。
I can't. It's tough to admit. Yeah. You can't fucking boil water. You know what, you know what's a better question? What do you suck at? What do you wish you were better at? Oh, boy, that's gonna sneak it right by them there, Will. I mean, we were both homeschooled so that we don't know any math.
我不能。很难承认。是的。你他妈的连水都烧不开。你知道什么，你知道什么是一个更好的问题？你在什么方面很烂？你希望你在什么方面更好？哦，天哪，Will，那会直接从他们身边溜过去。我的意思是，我们都是在家上学的，所以我们不懂任何数学。
Yeah, that's for sure. Oh, wow. We don't know any academics at all. I don't understand anything about the word geometry. They couldn't tell you. Like, I don't even know what it means. Sorry. You're fine. You're not gonna need it.
是的，那是肯定的。哦，哇。我们根本不懂任何学术。我不明白关于几何这个词的任何东西。他们不能告诉你。就像，我甚至不知道它是什么意思。抱歉。你很好。你不需要它。
Look at baby. That's what I'm saying, though. I don't need it. What am I gonna do with that? What am I gonna do with pie? You know, tell them. Jason, tell them you're school. Yeah, I didn't graduate.
看宝贝。这就是我说的，虽然。我不需要它。我能用它做什么？我能用派做什么？你知道，告诉他们。Jason，告诉他们你是学校。是的，我没毕业。
Well, and Jason, because I acted as a high, like I spent a fair amount of time on Glee as a young person and I was like, I feel like my not going to school equaled everyone else going to school and not learning anything. That was the feeling I got. That's what I felt, too. All of my friends went to school and none of us knew anything. It wasn't like I knew less. You know what?
嗯，而且Jason，因为我表现得像个高中，就像我年轻时在Glee上花了不少时间，我当时想，我觉得我没去上学等于其他人去上学却什么也没学到。那是我的感觉。那也是我的感觉。我所有的朋友都去上学了，我们谁也没学到什么。并不是说我知道得更少。你知道吗？
I gotta say, and this is gonna be controversial. I have the least amount of, because I did not graduate from college. I dropped out and everybody in my family has multiple degrees and I'm way smarter than all of them. See? They're gonna listen to this and be really put out. My dad went to Harvard and I'm way smarter than my dad. I'm always fascinated by musicians like yourself who either did or didn't study music.
我得说，这会引起争议。我拥有的最少，因为我没有从大学毕业。我退学了，我家里每个人都有多个学位，我比他们所有人都聪明得多。看到了吗？他们会听这个，并真的感到困扰。我爸爸去了哈佛，我比我爸爸聪明得多。我总是对像你这样的音乐家着迷，他们要么学了要么没学音乐。
Did you actually study music theory or anything like that? We actually did, but it was because we grew up in a choir and part of being in the choir was just doing music theory once a week, but it was fun. It wasn't like the way that school is horrible for people. No, but there were tests and stuff. Yeah, it was real. We did learn to read music, but that's not necessarily... You don't need to do that to make music at all.
你真的学过音乐理论或类似的东西吗？我们确实学过，但那是因为我们在唱诗班长大，作为唱诗班的一部分就是每周做一次音乐理论，但很有趣。它不像学校对人们来说那么可怕。不，但有考试什么的。是的，那是真的。我们确实学会了读乐谱，但这不一定……你根本不需要那样做来制作音乐。
Again, Paul McCartney was on. I asked him, I was like, what about this? And did you know that your time signature changes? And he's like, I don't know about any of that. And I was like, oh. And he's written symphonies, which is crazy. But it's more impressive. You guys know what you hear the music.
再次，Paul McCartney在节目上。我问他，我当时想，这个怎么样？你知道你的拍号变了吗？他说，我不知道那些。我当时想，哦。他写过交响乐，这很疯狂。但这更令人印象深刻。你们知道你们听到音乐。
You know what you like. You know what you're trying to say musically. And the fact that you can do it without having to sort of intellectualize it, it's just raw talent. You're kind of relying on that. I mean, you laugh at it. I know, but it's true. I think so.
你知道你喜欢什么。你知道你在音乐上想表达什么。事实上，你可以在不需要将其知识化的情况下做到这一点，这只是原始天赋。你有点依赖那个。我的意思是，你嘲笑它。我知道，但这是真的。我想是的。
What do I know? Well, thanks, guys. I'm just the smartest person in my family. I want to go back to what Jason was kind of touching on, which is where in the world do people like you get the confidence at such a young age when other people your age are like, it's kind of what Jason was talking about a little bit, which is, you know, like, what do you attribute your ability to perform in front of an audience? I could not tell you.
我懂什么？嗯，谢谢，伙计们。我只是我家最聪明的人。我想回到Jason有点触及的话题，那就是像你们这样的人在如此年轻的时候从哪里获得自信，当其他同龄人像，这有点像Jason刚才谈论的，就是，你知道，就像，你把你在观众面前表演的能力归功于什么？我无法告诉你。
I don't know. I kind of have a feeling of, I think it just depends what type of person you are. But I also kind of feel like some people change and be, I don't know. I don't really understand. I have a question for you. What? Are there times where you suddenly are either in the middle of a show or you walk on stage? You know what?
我不知道。我有点感觉，我想这取决于你是哪种人。但我也觉得有些人会改变，并且，我不知道。我真的不明白。我有一个问题要问你。什么？有没有时候你突然要么在演出中间，要么你走上舞台？你知道吗？
And sometimes we're like, I don't belong up here. That would be horrifying. That's a great question. Well, the only time it happened was, you know, I think at the end of 2019. So after I'd had this enormous year where, you know, I was becoming this, you know, name, which was so random and weird. I, you know, had like a month off of doing shows. It was like Thanksgiving.
有时我们想，我不属于这里。那会很可怕。这是一个很好的问题。嗯，唯一发生的时候是，你知道，我想在2019年底。所以在我度过了这极其重要的一年之后，你知道，我正在成为这个，你知道，名字，这太随机和奇怪了。我，你知道，有像一个月没做演出。那是感恩节。
It was about to be the holidays. And I had this one radio show and I went on stage and the entire show, I felt like I was pretending to be Billie Eilish. Swear to God. Like I had this whole feeling in my body that I was like, why am I doing, and it sounds crazy, why am I doing a Billie Eilish show for her? Like I'm not. I felt like a parody of myself and it was very trippy, took me many weeks to get out
快到假期了。我有一场电台节目，我走上舞台，整场演出，我觉得我在假装是Billie Eilish。发誓。就像我身体里有这种感觉，我当时想，我为什么要这样做，这听起来很疯狂，我为什么要为她做Billie Eilish的演出？就像我不是。我觉得自己是自己的模仿，这非常迷幻，花了我很多周才走出来
of that weird headspace, but I don't, I don't ever feel like I don't belong. You know, being on stage really is the one thing in my entire life that I've actually felt like I belonged in, you know, I had a lot of hobbies growing up and I still do. But I realized this recently that I actually never got to a place in any sport I did or any sort of hobby or whatever or class or anything, even things I loved, I never actually felt like I belonged there, but not in like, oh, I'm an outcast way. It just, there was something off and just being on stage is the first time I felt. You can feel it in the music that you guys write.
那种奇怪的头脑空间，但我没有，我从来没有觉得我不属于这里。你知道，站在舞台上确实是我一生中唯一真正让我觉得我属于这里的事情，你知道，我成长过程中有很多爱好，现在仍然有。但我最近意识到，我实际上在任何我做的运动或任何爱好或什么或课程或任何事情中都没有达到一个地方，即使是我喜欢的事情，我从来没有真正觉得我属于那里，但不是像，哦，我是个局外人。只是，有什么不对劲，站在舞台上是我第一次感觉到。你可以在你们写的音乐中感觉到它。
It feels very authentic. It feels like you guys are talking about what you're feeling, what you're going through. The music, it doesn't feel like you guys are pressing into some area that you are incapable of doing. It just sounds very personal, both musically and lyrically, and it's, and yet every single song is different. I think we talked about this a long time ago, they got Jimmy's show. There aren't two songs that sound the same.
它感觉非常真实。感觉你们在谈论你们的感受，你们正在经历的事情。音乐，它感觉不像你们在强行进入你们无法做到的领域。它听起来非常个人化，无论是在音乐上还是歌词上，而且，然而每一首歌都是不同的。我想我们很久以前谈过这个，他们上了Jimmy的节目。没有两首歌听起来是一样的。
That's so sweet of you. That's hard to do. I would imagine. Yeah, that's what I was saying at the beginning when everybody, everybody on this Zoomer was making fun of me. I was trying to get the point across that it is, it's such a departure from what was mainstream or what still is mainstream, that even if you liked it or you hate it or whatever, you couldn't help but take notice of it because it was so different and in your face and artistic
你太甜了。这很难做到。我想象。是的，这就是我一开始说的，当这个Zoomer上的每个人都在取笑我时。我试图表达的观点是，它是，它与主流或仍然是主流的东西如此背离，以至于即使你喜欢它或你讨厌它或随便，你也不得不注意到它，因为它太不同了，而且在你的脸上，艺术的
and thoughtful. Yeah, not easy. Yeah. I love that. I remember the first time I heard bad guy and I was like, what is this? There was such a sort of a danger to it, obviously, and there was like this kind of, you know, driving to school with my sons listening to it and thinking like, what? Who is this?
和深思熟虑的。是的，不容易。是的。我喜欢那个。我记得我第一次听到bad guy时，我当时想，这是什么？它显然有一种危险，而且有这种，你知道，开车送我儿子去学校听它，心想，什么？这是谁？
This is very unusual. That's awesome. Yeah, it's fucking rad, man. Really rad. Thanks. Will, are you in your Batman booth in the living room? Where are you? We're down in the Batcave right now.
这非常不寻常。那太棒了。是的，这他妈的很酷，伙计。真的很酷。谢谢。Will，你在客厅的蝙蝠侠展位里吗？你在哪？我们现在在蝙蝠洞里。
The Jack Shack. I'm in the Jack, what we call the Jack Shack. So sad. It's so gross. That's horrible. It's really gross. It's named after Sean. The sort of that dark sort of subversive nature of some of those songs, that's what I was
Jack Shack。我在Jack，我们称之为Jack Shack。太悲伤了。太恶心了。那太可怕了。真的很恶心。它是以Sean的名字命名的。那些歌曲中那种黑暗的、颠覆性的本质，那就是我
so surprised to find out that your parents are so close to you guys, too, and on the road and everything. I was like, oh, so it's not unsafe music, you know, for like, it's okay. The parents are on board with it, so it must just be just the skin of it, because, you know, my daughter was listening to a lot of it, like, oh, my God, is this too adult for her? Is it too? Sure.
非常惊讶地发现你们的父母也和你们这么亲近，在路上什么的。我当时想，哦，所以这不是不安全的音乐，你知道，对于像，没关系。父母支持它，所以它一定只是它的皮毛，因为，你知道，我女儿听了很多，就像，哦，天哪，这对她来说太成人了吗？太？当然。
And then you see the parents, you're like, oh, no, I got to listen to the lyrics. We did some interview, like, right before the first album came out, or the album, the only one we've put out so far. But right before that album came out, we did some interview on a radio station. And I remember the person interviewing us was like, why is the music you make so dark? Like, why did you make such dark music? And I don't remember exactly what the headline in the news was, but it was just sort of like, you know, it was a dark four years sort of geopolitically, and there was a lot of like
然后你看到父母，你就像，哦，不，我得听听歌词。我们在第一张专辑出来之前做了一些采访，或者专辑，我们目前为止只出了一张。但在那张专辑出来之前，我们在电台做了一些采访。我记得采访我们的人说，为什么你们制作的音乐这么黑暗？就像，为什么你们制作这么黑暗的音乐？我不记得新闻里的标题到底是什么，但它只是有点像，你知道，在地缘政治上这是一个黑暗的四年，而且有很多像
school shootings in the middle of our album. And I remember sort of just saying to her like, and like forest fires and shit. Yeah. Everything was like burning down and people were being shot at festivals and stuff. And I remember just sort of being so annoyed that her... Yeah, why are you guys so dark? Like, guys, the world is dark, though, you know? Yeah.
校园枪击案在我们专辑中间。我记得有点只是对她说，就像，还有森林火灾什么的。是的。一切都像在燃烧，人们在节日里被枪击什么的。我记得只是有点对她的……感到如此恼火。是的，为什么你们这么黑暗？就像，伙计们，世界是黑暗的，虽然，你知道吗？是的。
I remember just kind of being like, we're just sort of reflecting like what we're seeing in the world. Right. And sort of it's showing up in your art. It would be hard for it to not, which I was thinking like, during this lockdown shit, when it's been kind of a dark time, and of course we go ahead and start doing a comedy podcast and I'm like, God, we're so cynical. We don't even know the world around us.
我记得只是有点像，我们只是在反映我们在这个世界上看到的东西。对。而且它出现在你们的艺术中。如果不这样会很难，我在想，在这次封锁期间，当这是一个有点黑暗的时期，当然我们继续开始做一个喜剧播客，我当时想，天哪，我们太愤世嫉俗了。我们甚至不知道我们周围的世界。
The thing is that we never went for a dark song or a like cynical song. We were just writing about things we were wanting to write about. And it's the same with this album we're working on. It's just songs, you know, they all have their own world of, I don't know what I'm saying. So what are you, so because I'm an idiot, what is the category of music? It's not pop. Is it electropop? Or do you hate subcategories and categories and?
问题是，我们从来没有追求一首黑暗的歌或一首愤世嫉俗的歌。我们只是在写我们想写的东西。我们正在制作的这张专辑也是一样。它只是歌，你知道，它们都有自己的世界，我不知道我在说什么。那么你是，所以因为我是个白痴，音乐的类别是什么？它不是流行。是电子流行吗？还是你讨厌子类别和类别？
I don't know. I don't know. Perfect. It's just good. And it's successful. It's just great. Yeah. That's what it is.
我不知道。我不知道。完美。它只是好。而且它很成功。它只是很棒。是的。就是这样。
Is that what you've been doing in this time? So have you guys been working on a record this whole year type thing? The whole year, for real. I mean, I don't know how we would have made an album because, you know, we were planning before COVID obviously to make an album and put it out in 2021, but now having had this whole year of break, you know, I really don't know how we would have done it with the actual schedule that our year was supposed to be like. We weren't even supposed to be home, you know.
这就是你这段时间一直在做的吗？所以你们这一整年都在制作唱片吗？整整一年，真的。我的意思是，我不知道我们怎么能制作一张专辑，因为，你知道，我们在COVID之前显然计划制作一张专辑并在2021年发布，但现在有了这一整年的休息，你知道，我真的不知道我们怎么能用我们这一年本应有的实际时间表来完成它。我们甚至不应该在家，你知道。
Yeah. You guys are supposed to be on tour, right? Yeah. All year. I guess the set list or whatever you call it when your plan is going to be so fun on the next tour because it's all the songs you didn't get behind the last one and all the new ones. People go crazy.
是的。你们本应该在巡演，对吧？是的。整年。我想歌单或者不管你叫什么，当你的计划在下一次巡演时会很有趣，因为它是所有你没能支持上一张专辑的歌和所有新歌。人们会疯掉的。
I can't. Are you guys like so ready to get out there and play? Oh, I dream about it. I just, it's all I want. You don't want to stay home for another eight months? No, I don't. You're talking to a guy in pajamas. I think there was a middle period where there was no vaccine, where there was a kind of
我不能。你们准备好出去表演了吗？哦，我梦见它。我只是，这是我想要的全部。你不想再在家待八个月吗？不，我不想。你在和一个穿睡衣的家伙说话。我想有一个中间时期，没有疫苗，有一种
a surrendering to the whole thing of like, I guess this is forever, right? And now that there's like light at the end of the tunnel, it's worse. Yeah. It's kind of worse. So it sounds like you guys do like being out on the road. You like the bus, you like the hotels, you like the routine of a show and then going to bed late and sleeping late. As long as it's thought through and not punishing, yes.
对整件事的投降，就像，我想这是永远的，对吧？现在隧道尽头有了光，情况更糟了。是的。有点更糟了。所以听起来你们确实喜欢在路上。你们喜欢巴士，喜欢酒店，喜欢演出的常规，然后晚睡晚起。只要它是经过深思熟虑的而不是惩罚性的，是的。
What would it look like if it was punishing? Well, there were the first couple of years of me being me. I was 14, 15, and then 16, touring for the first time. And I was also very depressed because I was 14, 15, 16 as you are. And also, you know, at that level, you really grind, like it's the only word I can really come up with. You're just doing so much and I also was new to fame and suddenly I didn't have any friends because I was famous and I was leaving all the time and it was weird.
如果它是惩罚性的会是什么样子？嗯，我作为我自己的头几年。我14，15岁，然后16岁，第一次巡演。而且我也很沮丧，因为我14，15，16岁，正如你一样。而且，你知道，在那个水平上，你真的磨练，就像我能想到的唯一词。你只是做了很多，而且我也刚接触名声，突然我没有任何朋友，因为我很出名，我一直在离开，这很奇怪。
It was really weird. I'm really glad that I grew up a little bit and have found just ways of making it fun. She loves her crew, too. I love my crew. They're all like my friends, you know? And I also have a rule. I don't go on. Sorry, Will.
真的很奇怪。我很高兴我长大了一点，找到了让它变得有趣的方法。她也爱她的团队。我爱我的团队。他们都像我的朋友，你知道吗？而且我也有一个规则。我不去。抱歉，Will。
I also have a rule that I don't go out on tour straight for like four weeks. Four weeks is like the max that I'll be fully gone without a break. I can come home for like two weeks and go back out, but it's just when you're on tour for more than three or four weeks straight, it just, it starts to feel like a chore and I really don't want it to feel like a chore, you know? Because I love it. And I don't, you know, it's just... No, that sounds really, first of all, that sounds really well thought out and that's
我也有一个规则，我不连续巡演四个星期。四个星期是我在没有休息的情况下完全离开的最长时间。我可以回家两周再出去，但当你连续巡演超过三四个星期时，它只是，它开始感觉像一件苦差事，我真的不想让它感觉像一件苦差事，你知道吗？因为我爱它。而且我不，你知道，它只是……不，那听起来真的，首先，那听起来真的经过深思熟虑，那是一种
a very sort of mature kind of sober approach to it, knowing what your limits are and knowing what probably if you were to push that, that you would not only would the product maybe not be as good, but you'd start to resent the process a little bit. Exactly. And you don't want to get into that headspace. And I was going to ask you about your friends, like you mentioned early on when you're out there when you're 14, 15, you're probably, like you were saying, you're not with your friends and you probably have friends back home.
非常成熟的清醒方法，知道你的极限是什么，知道如果你推动那个，你不仅产品可能不会那么好，而且你会开始有点怨恨这个过程。完全正确。你不想进入那种头脑空间。我正要问你关于你的朋友，就像你早些时候提到的，当你14，15岁时，你可能，就像你说的，你没有和你的朋友在一起，你可能在家里有朋友。
That social aspect must be super difficult, kind of disconnecting. So weird. Yeah. Because when you're that age, you don't really know how to talk to grownups and they don't really know how to talk to you. Right. And other kids my age that I was friends with back home, like they're not going to pause their life and wait for me to get back and do things with me again.
那种社交方面一定超级困难，有点脱节。太奇怪了。是的。因为当你那个年纪时，你真的不知道怎么和大人说话，他们真的不知道怎么和你说话。对。而我在家里认识的其他同龄朋友，就像他们不会暂停他们的生活，等我回来再和我一起做事情。
Obviously, nobody should do that. You know, things happen and you move on with your life with or without somebody, but it was really hard for me because I just didn't know how to talk to anybody I worked with. Maybe it was over 40 and I was 14, 15 and I just didn't, it was just not good. It just wasn't, and it was waking up at like 8 a.m. to do radio press and having multiple shows and like acoustic performances and then on camera things, like so many things in a day for a 15 year old and then I get laryngitis and then I get like the flu and have to keep doing all this stuff.
显然，没有人应该那样做。你知道，事情发生了，你继续你的生活，无论有没有某人，但这对我来说真的很难，因为我只是不知道怎么和我一起工作的人说话。也许是40多岁，我14，15岁，我只是不知道，这只是不好。这只是不是，而且是早上8点起床做电台新闻，有多次演出和像原声表演，然后是镜头前的事情，就像一天中对一个15岁的人来说有这么多事情，然后我得了喉炎，然后我得了流感，不得不继续做所有这些事情。
So it did get to a point then where I resented it and then I just talk shit about it. All I could do was like, fuck fame, I hate being famous, I hate all of this and I couldn't go anywhere and I was 14 not being able to like go out in the world and that was super weird because I wasn't used to it because I was a little kid. Did you ever resent the fact that Phineas could walk down the street? You guys are both doing this thing, you're pulling equal weight, equal time, equal creative input, but Phineas gets the anonymity and he gets to walk down the street and live his life normally.
所以它确实到了那个地步，我怨恨它，然后我只是说它的坏话。我能做的只是，去他妈的名声，我讨厌出名，我讨厌这一切，我哪儿也去不了，我14岁不能像去世界上，那超级奇怪，因为我不习惯它，因为我还是个小孩子。你有没有怨恨过Phineas可以走在街上？你们俩都在做这件事，你们承担相等的重量，相等的时间，相等的创造性投入，但Phineas得到了匿名，他可以走在街上，正常生活。
I did, I was jealous for a while but now I'm like, I'm good, like now I feel, because now I'm confident in my life and I'm very happy with where it is and I would not take it back or change anything really even though there were a couple years that were really hard because I just think my life is at a place that I just, I'm so grateful for and very aware of how amazing it is and I really enjoy it, you know, before COVID and I was doing all these arena tours and stuff, it was just pure joy, dude, there's no other feeling. Were you able to rekindle some of those childhood relationships and friendships?
我确实，我嫉妒了一段时间，但现在我像，我很好，就像现在我感觉，因为现在我对我的生活充满信心，我对它所处的位置非常满意，我不会收回或改变任何事情，即使有几年真的很艰难，因为我只是认为我的生活处于一个我只是，我非常感激，并且非常清楚它是多么令人惊叹，我真的很享受它，你知道，在COVID之前，我做了所有这些竞技场巡演什么的，那只是纯粹的快乐，伙计，没有其他感觉。你能够重燃那些童年的关系和友谊吗？
The ones that mattered. The ones that mattered? Yeah, for sure. It was kind of good, you got to drop the ones that didn't matter. I was so lucky, I wish I could have dropped so many relationships. Because we have a couple that didn't, they're going to be on the show in about one minute. Oh my God. Hey Phineas, what was that like for you watching your sister go through that and you're going
那些重要的。那些重要的？是的，当然。这很好，你得放弃那些不重要的。我很幸运，我希望我能放弃那么多关系。因为我们有几个没有，他们大约一分钟后就会出现在节目上。哦，天哪。嘿Phineas，看着你妹妹经历那个，你感觉如何
through it together but watching her, so much of the spotlight is on her shining so bright and you know when that's happening. He didn't want that shit. Yeah, well you don't want it but it's kind of like a helicopter light, like you can't get out of it and every aspect of your life and so she's your sister and you guys are tight. The fame thing was really alarming as a like, I mean it would have been alarming as a friend or anything but as a big brother it was like especially weird because we're talking like
一起经历它，但看着她，聚光灯下有这么多照在她身上，闪耀得如此明亮，你知道当那发生时。他不想那样。是的，嗯，你不想，但这有点像直升机灯，就像你无法摆脱它，你生活的每一个方面，所以她是你的妹妹，你们很亲密。名声的事情真的很令人担忧，就像，我的意思是，作为朋友或任何事情会很令人担忧，但作为哥哥，这就像特别奇怪，因为我们在谈论像
pre-driving years and stuff for Billy too so sometimes I'd be like let's go get lunch and it would just be this pandemonium in a way that I hadn't thought it would be at all and like I remember one time we went and saw a concert and it was like this was before you know we'd like Billy had security or anything and so it was just like her scrawny bouncer brother, like I was like the worst security detail of all time and like just all these kids at this you know venue so it was kind of alarming. Well it was also alarming then because it was a small level of fame but it had all the moments of bad parts of fame.
开车前的几年什么的，对Billy也是，所以有时我会说我们去吃午饭，这会变成这种混乱，以一种我根本没想到的方式，就像我记得有一次我们去看了音乐会，就像这是在你，你知道，我们像Billy有保安什么的之前，所以它只是像她瘦骨嶙峋的保镖哥哥，就像我是有史以来最差的保安细节，就像在这个，你知道，场馆里的所有这些孩子，所以这有点令人担忧。嗯，那时也很令人担忧，因为那是小水平的名声，但它有所有名声坏部分的时刻。
This is a really dark thing to say but like a lot of the most sort of sinister scary levels of like stalkers and stuff is not like Lady Gaga fame, it's like the first echelon of like a lot of subscribers on YouTube. Because you're not big enough for people to really think you need protection but you're small enough for people to really get to reach you. And on a very real note protection is massively expensive so until you're making enough money to afford security details you just can't afford like your own safety anymore. It's very shitty.
这是一个非常黑暗的事情，但就像很多最那种险恶的、可怕的水平，像跟踪者什么的，不是像Lady Gaga的名声，而是像YouTube上很多订阅者的第一梯队。因为你不够大，人们真的认为你需要保护，但你足够小，人们真的可以接触到你。而且在一个非常真实的角度上，保护是非常昂贵的，所以直到你赚到足够的钱来负担保安细节，你只是再也负担不起像你自己的安全了。这非常烂。
It's weird. It's really weird. Let me just say this I'm in Los Angeles and you guys can't see but I've been working out a lot and so if you need some muscle. Just like on the weekends maybe? Well just do like the matinees Will. Yeah I'll do matinees. You guys need security for matinees?
很奇怪。真的很奇怪。让我只说这个，我在洛杉矶，你们看不到，但我一直在锻炼，所以如果你需要一些肌肉。只是像在周末吗？嗯，只是做像日场，Will。是的，我会做日场。你们需要日场保安吗？
Cause I do go to bed at 9pm. I have just like a stock stupid dumbass question. Oh great. Well then roll it out for sure, make sure to interrupt the conversation with a stupid question. I want to know it's a question you've been asked a billion times I'm sure but I don't know the answer which is what were your early influences as far as songwriting guys? Oh shit.
因为我确实在晚上9点睡觉。我有一个像库存愚蠢的笨蛋问题。哦，太棒了。那肯定把它拿出来，确保用一个愚蠢的问题打断谈话。我想知道这是一个你被问过十亿次的问题，我肯定，但我不知道答案，那就是你们作为词曲作者的早期影响是什么，伙计们？哦，该死。
Jesus fucking Christ. Guys I'm sorry. Are we done? Are we done? We're just auditioning. We're looking for a new third guys. As a fan I want to know. I want to know like who inspired you as songwriters.
耶稣他妈的基督。伙计们，我很抱歉。我们完了吗？我们完了吗？我们只是在试镜。我们在寻找一个新的第三人。作为一个粉丝，我想知道。我想知道像谁启发了你们作为词曲作者。
If anybody. And then roll it into your favorite color just after that. And who if you were a tree. What kind of tree? Willow. I think both of us weeping willow. I love a weeping willow. Or a cherry blossom.
如果有人。然后在那之后把它卷入你最喜欢的颜色。还有如果你是一棵树。什么树？柳树。我想我们俩都是垂柳。我喜欢垂柳。或者樱花。
What a great question. What's your first question? Our inspirations growing up. Please say mom and dad. Many many many inspirations. Musical you mean musical right Sean? What music do you listen to? Of course I mean musical and songwriting I said in songwriting.
多么好的问题。你的第一个问题是什么？我们成长过程中的灵感。请说妈妈和爸爸。很多很多很多灵感。音乐，你的意思是音乐，对吧Sean？你听什么音乐？我当然是指音乐和词曲创作，我说的是词曲创作。
But look it seems to be a really horrible question that I can't imagine anybody would want to know. Do you start to when you start getting some of those like old chestnuts the ones you get in every single interview. Do you guys start to make each other laugh privately by answering the same question with a clearly different answer that only you both know is total BS. That's really funny. It's bad when we have to do an interview together that's like a real serious one.
但看，这似乎是一个非常可怕的问题，我无法想象有人会想知道。当你开始得到一些像那些老栗子，你在每次采访中得到的那些时，你们开始通过用一个显然不同的答案回答同一个问题来私下让对方发笑，只有你们俩知道那是完全的BS。那真的很有趣。当我们不得不一起做一个采访时，那是一个真正严肃的采访，这很糟糕。
Sure. It's bad. And the questions are always like. Oh my god. You know one time somebody asked us how we met. Come on. That was nuts. Those are bonkers.
当然。这很糟糕。而且问题总是像……天哪。你知道有一次有人问我们是怎么认识的。拜托。那太疯狂了。那些问题简直不可理喻。
Was the person's name Sean Hayes was that the interviewer? Just because I think it's blatant disrespectful to not answer the question Sean. I was going to answer it eventually. I was going to answer it. Sean went into this a fan he's going to we're going to finish this and that chip has sailed after the first. No but I was going to answer it I was going to answer it. It's our fault.
那个人叫肖恩·海耶斯吗？他是采访者吗？只是因为我觉得不回答肖恩的问题是公然的不尊重。我本来打算最终回答的。我本来打算回答的。肖恩进来时是个粉丝，他打算……我们要结束这个采访，那个机会在第一次之后就溜走了。不，但我本来打算回答的，我本来打算回答的。这是我们的错。
Jason and I have been misbehaving. Sean's been side texting me hateful things about the both of you. These guys their egos are enormous. But go ahead answer your give them your answer. We grew up listening to like a ton of the Beatles. That was a huge part of writing inspiration. Yeah. Lana Del Rey was big for us.
杰森和我不守规矩。肖恩一直在私下给我发关于你们俩的刻薄话。这些家伙的自我意识太强了。但继续吧，回答你的……给他们你的答案。我们从小听了很多披头士乐队的歌。那是创作灵感的重要组成部分。是的。拉娜·德雷对我们影响很大。
You loved Green Day. Yeah. You loved a lot of like underground SoundCloud rap. That was very inspiring. Aurora. See I think that's interesting. You guys released that first song on SoundCloud right and it just like what exploded there were you guys watching the numbers tick up was it were you did you put it up there hoping
你喜欢绿日乐队。是的。你喜欢很多像SoundCloud上的地下说唱。那非常鼓舞人心。奥罗拉。我觉得这很有趣。你们在SoundCloud上发布了第一首歌，对吧，然后它就像……爆炸了，你们当时在看着数字上涨吗？你们把它放上去是希望
that it would get traction or was it just like well we're done with this let's put it up there maybe some people listen to it. Exactly that. Yeah. Second thing you said it was very odd that it got any attention at all. The reason we even made it in the first place was because my I danced a lot and my dance teacher was like Billy could you make a song and I could like choreograph a dance to it and I thought that was you know the coolest thing I'd ever heard even though it wasn't
它能获得关注，还是仅仅觉得“好吧，我们做完了，把它放上去吧，也许有人会听”？正是那样。是的。你说的第二点，它能得到任何关注都非常奇怪。我们最初制作它的原因是因为我跳了很多舞，我的舞蹈老师说：“比莉，你能做一首歌，让我能为它编舞吗？”我觉得那是（你知道的）我听过的最酷的事情，尽管它
going to be like anything it was just like you know some random dance but I was like sure and we finished had this song and we so whatever we record it blah blah blah and we were gonna just send it to him and not put it up anywhere but we were like I mean it's it's this song we made we might as well put it on SoundCloud like for our friends to listen to there was like a free download link on it there was you know we didn't expect anything though and kind of crazy just in the next couple days it just like grew and grew and grew. But it was a small growth.
不会成为什么大作，它只是（你知道的）一些随意的舞蹈，但我说“当然”，我们完成了这首歌，所以无论如何，我们录制了它，巴拉巴拉，我们本来只是想把它发给他，不把它放在任何地方，但我们想，我的意思是，这是我们制作的歌，我们不妨把它放在SoundCloud上，让我们朋友听听。上面有一个免费下载链接，你知道的，我们没期待什么，但接下来的几天里，它真的就像……增长、增长、再增长。但那是一个小规模的增长。
It was a small growth it wasn't it seems like oh it went viral and then I became a star and not at all it got like a thousand plays that's how much and we were just over the moon. Your boy Bieber kind of you launched like that right. Yeah. By people fans like you of him. Yeah. Correct.
那是一个小规模的增长，它并不是看起来的那种“它火了，然后我成了明星”，完全不是，它大概有一千次播放，就是这样，我们当时简直欣喜若狂。你的那个比伯也是那样起步的，对吧。是的。被像你这样的粉丝。是的。没错。
Your boy Bieber. She loves Biebs. Oh she might but just like you're on like you're on the inside. Yeah. Fuck off man. Let me tell you something Arnett. I tried during. So demeaning.
你的那个比伯。她喜欢比伯。哦，她可能喜欢，但就像你……你是在圈内。是的。滚开，伙计。让我告诉你一件事，阿内特。我试过……太贬低人了。
That Bieber documentary made me cry. Okay. And anybody that likes Bieber. Oh me too. Oh yeah. I like so I'll tell you a true story. This is this is embarrassing because I've done so much stupid shit like this. I was at the at the U.S. Open years ago and they do this thing the day before it starts
那部比伯纪录片让我哭了。好吧。任何喜欢比伯的人。哦，我也是。哦，是的。我喜欢……所以我给你讲个真实的故事。这很尴尬，因为我做过很多像这样的蠢事。多年前我在美国网球公开赛，他们在比赛开始前一天做了一件事
and it was me and Will Ferrell playing tennis against Andy Murray and Andy Roddick and we're playing them. There was this kid who was going to play some music right before the thing. It was like on a Sunday and the kids like hey will say to Farrell he was like hey will can I get on a maybe I should do like a funnier dive video or something. And I said I remember saying to Will I was like hey will you super psyched that the nine year old wants to do a video with you and it turned out it was Justin. Oh my God.
当时是我和威尔·法瑞尔打网球，对手是安迪·穆雷和安迪·罗迪克。有个孩子要在活动前表演音乐，对吧。那是在一个周日，那孩子说：“嘿，威尔，对法瑞尔说，嘿威尔，我能上个……也许我应该拍个更有趣的视频什么的。”我记得我对威尔说：“嘿威尔，你超级兴奋那个九岁的孩子想和你拍视频吗？”结果发现那是贾斯汀。天哪。
Did he do it with him? Yeah of course he did it. I would just watch it every day. He did do it. He did do it. And I was like and I'm so I had a similar thing too with my buddy had his friend he's like I'm spinning. I'm a DJ.
他和他一起拍了吗？是的，当然拍了。我每天都会看。他确实拍了。他确实拍了。我当时就像……我也有过类似的经历，我的哥们有个朋友，他说“我在打碟。我是个DJ。”
This is like 1992 in New York and he's like are you going to come to our show. He's like I got a show down in Canal Street. I'm like yeah I'm coming to your show Moby. Oh wow. And then and then what about yeah you kind of tisk at that stock tip you got on Netflix and the other one for Uber right. Yeah because I was like every movie every TV show and movie that you want in your house on your computer.
那是1992年的纽约，他说“你要来我们的演出吗？”他说“我在运河街有个演出。”我说“好的，我会去你的演出，莫比。”哦，哇。然后呢……还有那个你在Netflix和优步上得到的股票建议，对吧。是的，因为我当时想，你家里电脑上想要的每一部电影和电视节目。
I was like yeah sure sounds like a great idea. Can I ask another fan question here it comes guys hold on. Okay. Thank you. Thank you. It's and a lot of these are for my sister in Wisconsin too. So I am a huge James Bond fan. I know you guys wrote the song No Time to Die.
我当时想“是的，当然，听起来是个好主意。”我能再问一个粉丝问题吗？来了，伙计们，等等。好的。谢谢。谢谢。这是……而且其中很多也是为了我在威斯康星州的姐姐。所以我是一个超级詹姆斯·邦德粉丝。我知道你们写了《无暇赴死》这首歌。
So two of my favorite things are going to be on the screen at the same time James Bond and Billie Eilish. So I love the song I love I think it's amazing but here's the thing that I get to ask you which I've always wanted to ask somebody who wrote a Bond song and performed a Bond song. Did you guys have like did you have to work with the Bond estate like do they put certain guidelines or influence on how the song should be or do they mold it together or do they leave you alone and trust you. Great question.
所以我有两个最爱的东西将同时出现在屏幕上：詹姆斯·邦德和比莉·艾利什。所以我喜欢这首歌，我喜欢……我觉得它太棒了，但这里有一件事我要问你们，我一直想问一个写过邦德歌曲并演唱过邦德歌曲的人。你们当时是否必须与邦德遗产管理方合作？他们是否对歌曲应该是什么样设定了某些指导方针或影响？或者他们是让你们一起塑造它，还是让他们放手让你们自己做，并信任你们？好问题。
It that's a great question. You're also you're very sweet. I appreciate all the compliments it's really nice to hear. He's vicious. You don't need to help him. It was very collaborative. The beginning of the process which is what somebody says when it's like wasn't collaborative. No no no it was it was it was they didn't just say go write a song and it can be anything
那是个好问题。你也很可爱。我很感激所有的赞美，听到这些真的很好。他很恶毒。你不需要帮他。这非常有协作性。过程的开始……这是某人在事情并不怎么协作时会说的话。不，不，不，它确实是……他们并没有只是说“去写一首歌，它可以是任何东西”
and then we'll use it. It was you know it was would you guys be open to writing a song and we were like no shit and then basically the steps were they sent us the script from like the first scene the opening scene and that's all we got but it was kind of it kind of showed what the movie was about and then she kind of Barbara Broccoli kind of gave us a little bit of what the movie was about and and what Barbara Broccoli is the producer of all the James Bond songs. Yeah and she that was basically what we got and we you know the Bond songs are are a very high standard for us.
然后我们就会用它。它是……你知道的，它是“你们愿意写一首歌吗？”我们当时说“废话”，然后基本上步骤是他们把第一场戏的剧本发给我们，开场戏，这就是我们得到的全部，但它展示了电影是关于什么的，然后她……芭芭拉·布洛柯里给了我们一点关于电影的内容，而且……芭芭拉·布洛柯里是所有詹姆斯·邦德歌曲的制片人。是的，她……那基本上就是我们得到的，我们……你知道，邦德歌曲对我们来说是一个非常高的标准。
It's a real honor and so we wanted to be really good and we thought about it really hard and worked really hard on it and well it paid off. It's awesome. Well thank you. It took a couple days of writer's block and then we came through and did it have to hit a certain time because it's always over the credits isn't it the credits. Yeah I think the very last step was sort of like making it right. Let's make it exactly this many seconds or something but but yeah I mean it really was
这真的是一种荣誉，所以我们想让它非常好，我们非常认真地思考了它，并为此付出了很多努力，嗯，它得到了回报。太棒了。嗯，谢谢。它花了几天的写作瓶颈期，然后我们完成了它，它必须达到特定的时间吗？因为它总是在片尾字幕时，不是吗？字幕。是的，我想最后一步有点像是把它做对。让我们把它做成正好这么多秒之类的，但……但是的，我的意思是，它确实是
this it was like on our you know fantasy lifelong bucket list of dreams of like maybe we could do a Bond song and I think it was one of those things where so after the album had come out it was sort of like what would you be interested in doing like who would you want to collaborate with and I think our team maybe was expecting us to be like you know say some other musician or something and we were like if they're making another Bond movie like let us know who we could like who we could beg to do that and wow. The Apple commercial was pretty awesome in that respect as well I mean that's a very pedigreed destination for songs nowadays isn't it.
这就像在我们……你知道，幻想终身愿望清单上的……也许我们可以做一首邦德歌曲，我想这是那种事情之一，所以在专辑发行后，有点像是“你对做什么感兴趣？你想和谁合作？”我想我们的团队可能期待我们说“你知道，说其他音乐家什么的”，而我们说“如果他们要拍另一部邦德电影，让我们知道我们可以……我们可以求谁来做那个”，哇。苹果广告在这方面也相当棒，我的意思是，那现在是歌曲的一个非常有声望的目的地，不是吗？
Yeah Bond and the Apple commercial thing were both very much like auditions in terms of like they were not an offer it was like we'd love to hear what you come up with and then once we had written the thing and presented it to them they you know they said let's play the ball which was very sweet of them. Jason I was a lot about auditions tell them Jason about your last audition that you had the last one. Before Arrested Development. Tell them.
是的，邦德和苹果广告的事情在很大程度上都像是试镜，因为它们不是邀请，而是“我们很想听听你们能想出什么”，然后一旦我们写好了东西并展示给他们，他们……你知道，他们说“让我们用这首歌”，这对他们来说非常贴心。杰森，我关于试镜说了很多，告诉他们杰森，关于你上次的试镜，你有的那次。最后一次。在《发展受阻》之前。告诉他们。
Oh this is for Can You Hear Me Now? Yeah. Yeah. Horizon. I got very close to getting that campaign and had I gotten it I don't think I would have gotten Arrested Development. But Jason if you'd gotten the Can You Hear Me Now campaign you would now many many years later be the Sprint guy saying can you hear that.
哦，这是为了《你能听到我吗？》。是的。是的。地平线。我非常接近得到那个活动，如果我得到了它，我想我不会得到《发展受阻》。但杰森，如果你得到了《你能听到我吗？》活动，你现在，很多很多年后，会是那个斯普林特（Sprint）的家伙，说着“你能听到吗？”
Yeah. And I'd have twice as much money. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I do want to swing back to in retrospect Sean's question wasn't as terrible as we gave him shit for it but it's more just more fun to give him shit for it than actually. But when you guys when you went out when you first started making your record and you were
是的。而且我会多赚两倍的钱。是的。是的。是的。我确实想回过头来说，回想起来，肖恩的问题并不像我们嘲笑的那样糟糕，但嘲笑他比实际情况更有趣。但是当你们……当你们刚开始制作唱片时，你们
you start to record you write a song or whatever did you have somebody in mind like who are the people you go like I hope I sound like or I hope I hope it's going to be like like here are the people that I really love right now especially you know. Like I'm not a musician at all but I know that I have five people who I'd want to sound like. That's a good one. That was that was it was a good one. It was one I haven't heard before sorry Sean.
开始录音，你写了一首歌什么的，你心里有别人吗？比如，你希望听起来像谁，或者我希望……我希望它会像……这里是我现在真正喜欢的人。我的意思是，我根本不是音乐家，但我知道我有五个我想听起来像的人。那是一个很好的问题。那是……那是……这是一个好问题。这是一个我以前没听过的，抱歉肖恩。
No I get it. I get it. James Bond was pretty good. That was more of a thing that was prominent when we were first starting like when like when we first started making music which was I was 13 and Phineas was 17 I think. That's crazy to think about. I don't remember feeling that we were that age anyway then it was totally and you know because I didn't know my sound at all.
不，我明白。我明白。詹姆斯·邦德相当不错。那更多是我们刚开始时比较突出的事情，就像……当我们刚开始做音乐时，我13岁，菲尼亚斯17岁，我想。想到这一点真是太疯狂了。我不记得当时觉得自己是那个年纪，无论如何，那是完全……而且你知道，因为我根本不知道我的声音。
I was just like we were like pure inspiration from sure yeah and that's the this is a thing I've always talked about which is that you know people get flack for copying others and I totally feel that and have felt that a lot but there's like a certain line of just being inspired versus carbon copy do you know what I mean because when you're starting out in anything in the world not just music you have to try things out to figure out what you like. It's the same with like personalities when you're 13 you meet a kid and you're like oh my god they're so cool I want to be more like them and you do things like them and you talk like them and you you have to do that to become what you are and that shouldn't be that shouldn't
我只是……我们就像纯粹的灵感，当然，是的，这就是……这是我一直谈论的事情，就是你知道人们因为抄袭他人而受到抨击，我完全理解这一点，并且感受过很多次，但有一种界限，就是受到启发与完全照搬，你知道我的意思吗？因为当你开始做世界上任何事情时，不仅仅是音乐，你必须尝试各种事情来找出你喜欢什么。这和个性一样，当你13岁时，你遇到一个孩子，你会想“天哪，他们太酷了，我想变得更像他们”，你做他们做的事，你像他们一样说话，你……你必须这样做才能成为现在的你，那不应该……那不应该
be pushed away like that shouldn't be turned away I guess. No we relate to that we do that I can't speak for these guys but I know that as a performer there are people that I looked up to who I thought were really funny or really witty I mean I love David Letterman I loved his delivery I love how dry he is and you know I was always like I wish I hope that I can cut somebody off and be really shitty and witty in the way he is. It's also a mission accomplished. I know the exact feeling but also you also catch yourself you as in anyone catch you
被推开，那不应该被拒绝，我想。不，我们对此有共鸣，我们确实这样做，我不能代表这些家伙，但我知道作为表演者，我仰慕的人，我觉得他们非常有趣或非常机智，我的意思是，我喜欢大卫·莱特曼，我喜欢他的表达方式，我喜欢他有多冷幽默，而且你知道，我总是想“我希望……我希望我能打断某人，并以他那样的方式变得非常刻薄和机智。”这也是任务完成。我知道那种确切的感觉，但同时你也会发现自己，你作为任何人，发现你
know I do it all the time or I'm like I'm kind of doing too much like this person that I admire and you have to just be aware that you're you're gonna end up accidentally copying someone just because you think they're dope but I think it's just important to remember that you can be inspired by someone you just can't completely copy them but you can be inspired and you should let yourself be inspired. But instinct is sort of like the child of being inspired by somebody right like you can't you can't get an idea to be or do something unless you have seen it or a version of it beforehand I mean it just.
你知道，我一直都在做，或者我像“我有点做得太多了，像这个我钦佩的人”，你必须意识到你……你最终会不小心抄袭某人，仅仅因为你认为他们很酷，但我认为重要的是要记住，你可以受到某人的启发，你只是不能完全抄袭他们，但你可以受到启发，你应该让自己受到启发。但直觉有点像是受到某人启发后的产物，对吧？就像你不能……你不能产生一个想法去做某事，除非你之前见过它或它的版本，我的意思是，它只是……
There are no original ideas in that way I mean Tarantino talks about it all the time he's a brilliant filmmaker he's made some brilliant films and he is also a student of films totally inspired by so many different styles yeah we listen to so the quantity of music we listen to is very very very high and I think you know one of the coolest parts about especially working on the second album over the past year has been that we're deep enough into our catalog that we're we're more internal than external you just kind of build enough of an environment where you're kind of pulling from yourself in an interesting way or your own I don't know do you feel that way at all Billy I was I was not listening
没有原创的想法，我的意思是，昆汀一直谈论它，他是一位出色的电影制作人，他制作了一些出色的电影，他也是电影的学生，完全受到这么多不同风格的启发，是的，我们听……我们听的音乐数量非常非常非常高，而且我认为你知道，尤其是过去一年在第二张专辑上的工作，最酷的部分之一是我们在我们的目录中足够深入，我们更多是内部而不是外部，你只是建立了一个足够的环境，你在以一种有趣的方式从你自己身上汲取，或者你自己的……我不知道，比莉，你完全有那种感觉吗？我当时……我没有在听
sorry what did you say great answer I was just saying that like when you because we're on like your second album that we've been working on and it's like now I feel like it's it's more like it's just being built upon itself as opposed to external influence do you know what I mean right sure yeah I think so absolutely well on that like do you guys when you when you start to write an album or song do you do you guys try to start as macro as possible like you think about theme or feel or tone and then come up with a melody then come up with lyrics and you start to get more and more and more micro or does it change per song per album it really changes per song it really does I forget that like anytime
抱歉，你说什么？很好的回答。我只是说，就像当你……因为我们正在制作你的第二张专辑，现在我觉得它……它更多是建立在它自身之上，而不是外部影响，你知道我的意思吗？对，当然，是的，我想绝对是。好吧，关于那个……你们在开始写专辑或歌曲时，你们是否尝试尽可能从宏观开始？比如你们考虑主题、感觉或基调，然后想出一个旋律，然后想出歌词，然后开始变得越来越微观，还是每首歌、每张专辑都在变？它确实每首歌都在变，真的。我忘记了……任何时候
I'm asked a question about how my writing process goes in our writing process I always feel like stupid answering it because I'm like but that's how everyone works and I realized recently that it's not that people write in all sorts of different ways and we write in a certain way and it's usually I mean it is random but it's usually out of like three ways ish where it can start with an instrument just playing chords whatever coming up with melodies then coming up with lyrics or it starts with a beat and then it's lyrics and it's melodies or it's you think of or it's concept yeah or it's one lyric or it's one melody like that you just it's random do you feel an obligation to have a
我被问到关于我的写作过程和我们的写作过程的问题时，我回答时总是觉得很蠢，因为我想“但这就是每个人的工作方式”，但我最近意识到并不是，人们以各种不同的方式写作，而我们以某种方式写作，它通常……我的意思是，它是随机的，但它通常来自三种方式左右，它可以从乐器开始，只是弹奏和弦，无论什么，想出旋律，然后想出歌词，或者它从节拍开始，然后是歌词和旋律，或者它……你想到……或者它是概念，是的，或者它是一句歌词，或者它是一个旋律，就像你只是……它是随机的。你是否感到有义务在
continuity between all of the songs so that the album is a hole in its tone in its sound or given the sort of a la carte nature of the industry now where you don't necessarily have to buy an album you can just kind of buy one song at a time do you guys feel like well let's just make each song great and if somebody finds a continuity thread through all of them then so be it but that's not the drive I feel the opposite I feel like a desire to not repeat ourselves yeah but also I do think it's important to have a project that feels cohesive yeah it doesn't feel like a bunch of clones it's just really been important to me to make music that doesn't sound like my other music I want to make a different
所有歌曲之间保持连续性，以便专辑在基调和声音上是一个整体？或者考虑到现在行业那种点菜式的性质，你不一定非要买一张专辑，你可以一次只买一首歌，你们是否觉得“好吧，让我们把每首歌都做好，如果有人在所有歌曲中找到了连续性线索，那就这样吧，但那不是动力”？我感觉相反，我感觉有一种不重复自己的渴望，是的，但我也确实认为拥有一个感觉连贯的项目很重要，是的，它感觉不像一堆克隆品，对我来说，制作听起来不像我其他音乐的音乐真的很重要，我想制作一个不同的
song every single time obviously you can't really fully do that 100% but you can kind of do it and what I like about this album we're working on and you know my debut album or whatever is that it was very different but it felt like from the same project it felt like the same body of work but different enough I don't know if that's even true but I gotta say I love I sort of notice that you keep saying every time you guys say like debut album and you kind of go over whatever and you're talking about there's a self awareness no it's really sweet you get there is a sort of a built in modesty that you guys have there because I know it sounds weird saying it and you feel like if I say debut album I'm bragging
每一次都是不同的歌，显然你不能真正完全做到100%，但你可以做到，我喜欢我们正在制作的这张专辑，你知道，我的首张专辑什么的，它非常不同，但感觉像是来自同一个项目，感觉像是同一个作品，但足够不同，我不知道这是否是真的，但我不得不说，我喜欢……我注意到你们每次说“首张专辑”时，你们有点……无论什么，你们在谈论时有一种自我意识，不，这真的很贴心，你们……有一种内在的谦虚，你们有那种谦虚，因为我知道说出来听起来很奇怪，你觉得如果我说“首张专辑”，我是在吹牛
I remember one time saying like never say the words my and career in the same sentence because you sound like a fucking jerk and you're like well my career like shut up you asshole but the truth is at the same time it is you know it is your debut album and you are working on your new album and there is maybe that thing it's I think anyway Jason could learn you guys are genuinely sincerely humble and modest is a part of that not only just the sincerity of it the genuineness of it but is there also sort of like a side benefit of if you stay sort of normal and grounded then you can appreciate all the crazy batshit fun stuff that's happening around it oh my god yes if you get jaded then it's just like
我记得有一次说“永远不要在同一个句子中说‘我的’和‘职业生涯’这两个词，因为你听起来像个该死的混蛋”，你会说“嗯，我的职业生涯”，闭嘴，你这个混蛋，但事实是，同时它确实是……你知道，它是你的首张专辑，你正在制作你的新专辑，也许有那种东西，我想无论如何，杰森可以学到……你们是真诚地谦虚和低调，这不仅仅是真诚，不仅仅是它的真实性，而且是否还有一种附带的好处，如果你保持正常和脚踏实地，那么你就可以欣赏周围所有疯狂的、疯狂的有趣事情？哦，天哪，是的，如果你变得厌倦了，那么它就像
you're yawning on stage oh my god it boggles my mind the shit that people do don't make it normal because then it stops being fun right exactly you stop being able to call people batshit yeah right right what is it that gets you guys really nervous now now that you guys are very good and accomplished and seasoned at a lot of things that you're doing are you guys thinking about areas that might get you outside your comfort zone well yeah also just performing to to piggyback on Jason's question because you already performed at the Grammys and the Oscars yeah the Oscars we were so nervous we were terrible at the Grammys and terrible at the Oscars we bombed the only two really big I literally I can't
你在舞台上打哈欠，哦，天哪，人们做的事情让我感到困惑，不要让它变得正常，因为那样它就不再有趣了，对吧？正是如此，你不再能称别人为疯狂，是的，对，对，现在是什么让你们感到非常紧张？既然你们在很多事情上都非常优秀、有成就且经验丰富，你们是否在考虑可能让你们走出舒适区的地方？嗯，是的，还有表演，为了呼应杰森的问题，因为你们已经在格莱美和奥斯卡上表演过了，是的，奥斯卡，我们太紧张了，我们在格莱美表现得很糟糕，在奥斯卡表现得很糟糕，我们搞砸了，唯一两个真正大的……我字面上……我不能
even look at pictures of me performing on a puke oh my god well you're good actors then the Oscars we were so scared the Oscars was the scariest thing because it's the coolest one of them all because actors are just classier than musicians they're just so nuts it's such a cliche right like actors get nervous around musicians and musicians get nervous about athletes and athletes get nervous about you know it's all grasses always greener well the difference between the Grammys and the Oscars is like everyone at the Grammys walks up on stage and their first thing we're like wow I wasn't expecting this and there's a lot of umming in Grammy acceptance speeches and like Oscar like everyone you know I mean
甚至看我表演时的照片，呕吐，哦，天哪，好吧，那你们是好演员，奥斯卡，我们太害怕了，奥斯卡是最可怕的事情，因为它是所有这些中最酷的，因为演员比音乐家更有格调，他们太疯狂了，这真是陈词滥调，对吧？就像演员在音乐家面前感到紧张，音乐家在运动员面前感到紧张，运动员在……你知道，草总是更绿，好吧，格莱美和奥斯卡之间的区别是，格莱美上的每个人走上舞台，他们的第一件事是“哇，我没想到会这样”，格莱美获奖感言中有很多“嗯”，像奥斯卡……每个人，你知道，我的意思是
most of them are actors but but even the you know sound mixing Oscar is they have written a speech it's so professional and like classy that it's very intimidating and I said that a lot after the Oscars and then there was articles were like Billy I was hates the Oscars and I was like no no no guys they're just really scary and I was not used to that environment I've never been to the Grammys but it does seem like sometimes like a battle of who could care less you know yeah absolutely people don't even show up sometimes yeah and they're like oh and today he's wearing a he's wearing a small fiat to uh like that's his wardrobe holy fuck it's also in the Staples Center and there's like thousands of actual audience
他们大多数是演员，但即使是……你知道，音效混音奥斯卡，他们写了演讲稿，它非常专业和有格调，以至于非常令人生畏，我在奥斯卡之后说了好多次，然后有文章说“比莉·艾利什讨厌奥斯卡”，我说“不，不，不，伙计们，它们只是真的很吓人，我不习惯那种环境”，我从来没去过格莱美，但它确实看起来有时像是一场“谁能更不在乎”的战斗，你知道，是的，绝对，人们有时甚至不出现，是的，他们说“哦，今天他穿着一个小菲亚特去……就像那是他的衣橱”，该死，它也在斯台普斯中心，有成千上万的实际观众
members and I think the Oscars is like you know it's I mean it's in that uh what is it the Hilton or the the Dolby but it's very intimate and it feels like wasn't there a question at the beginning of the question I want to know what get yeah what gets you guys nervous oh what do you find that that you dread like if it's something is planned on a certain day and you'd wake up in the morning you're like oh oh that's so good um talk shows it's talk shows for me is it really you're so good on talk shows though nah take a second look hang on will take a second right in the middle of a compliment fucking bore all three of you are great on well hang on finish thank you go on um no yeah
成员，我想奥斯卡是……你知道，它是……我的意思是，它在那个……希尔顿还是杜比剧院，但它非常亲密，感觉像是……开始时不是有个问题吗？我想知道是什么让……是的，什么让你们感到紧张？哦，你们发现什么让你们感到恐惧？如果某事计划在某一天，你早上醒来，你会想“哦，哦”，那太好了，嗯，脱口秀，对我来说是脱口秀，真的吗？你在脱口秀上表现得很好，不，再看一眼，等等，威尔，再看一眼，就在赞美中间，该死，你们三个都很棒，嗯，等等，完成，谢谢，继续，嗯，不，是的
it's the nerves that get me prepared for it you know if I wasn't nervous I'd probably be worse I get that it's the anticipation of it yeah but it is funny though because you never stopped dreading things I thought that maybe when I got to a certain age or success or whatever that maybe like I would never dread anything again and I dread things every day I just normal things I just dread them and that's that normal part of you that seems so healthy don't worry it only gets worse but it seems very healthy yeah but you know what's interesting is like you know Jason and Will and I have talked about this where I grew up in Chicago and so I didn't grow up at all around any kind of Hollywood Los Angeles your voice
是紧张让我为它做好了准备，你知道，如果我不紧张，我可能会表现得更糟，我明白，那是对它的期待，是的，但这很有趣，因为你永远不会停止对事情感到恐惧，我以为也许当我到了某个年龄或成就什么的，也许……我再也不会对任何事情感到恐惧了，我每天都对事情感到恐惧，我只是……正常的事情，我只是对它们感到恐惧，那是你身上看起来非常健康的那种正常部分，别担心，它只会变得更糟，但这看起来非常健康，是的，但你知道有趣的是，就像……你知道，杰森、威尔和我谈论过这个，我在芝加哥长大，所以我根本没有在任何好莱坞、洛杉矶的环境中长大，你的声音
sounds just like my uncle's voice well he's must be gay I don't know how Sean beat you to that one well sorry go on no I mean because he's an uncle let's just start there um but um no uh growing up in Chicago I would watch I told Jason I would watch Jason on TV when I was a little kid and I would watch movies and I would watch all these things and just dream and aspire to I still even when I would go on the universal lot I would drive just as a year ago I'd be like I can't believe I'm driving on the universal lot like it never goes away so what was it like for you guys to grow up in it because you don't have the perspective like I had which was it's so unattainable it's so far away but you guys actually grew up inside of it well we had that up until we were
听起来就像我叔叔的声音，好吧，他一定是同性恋，我不知道肖恩是怎么抢在你前面的，好吧，抱歉，继续，不，我的意思是，因为他是叔叔，让我们从那里开始，嗯，但是……嗯，不，嗯，在芝加哥长大，我会看……我告诉杰森，我小时候会在电视上看杰森，我会看电影，我会看所有这些东西，只是梦想和渴望……我仍然，即使我去环球影城，我也会开车，就在一年前，我会想“我不敢相信我在环球影城开车”，它永远不会消失，所以对你们来说，在其中长大是什么感觉？因为你们没有我那种视角，那就是它太遥不可及了，它太远了，但你们实际上是在里面长大的，嗯，我们在那之前一直有那种感觉，直到我们
13 and 17 so to me I do feel like I had that um because I also grew up a huge fan of like Beaver for instance complete fan like merch posters waiting in line blah blah blah and just to me just like you're saying it was completely irrational any idea of celebrity in general I was like there that doesn't happen to people so just because you grew up in LA doesn't mean you would accept it any easier no I think I think that there's like people think it would and and I think that LA definitely no not definitely anything I don't think it really did I mean for us because we didn't grow up we didn't have famous parents and our parents didn't have but they were both in the business right with it sure did that make it feel like sort of your
13岁和17岁，所以对我来说，我确实觉得我有那种……因为我也从小就是比伯的超级粉丝，完全是粉丝，比如周边、海报、排队什么的，对我来说，就像你说的，它是完全不合理的，任何关于名人的想法，总的来说，我当时想“那不会发生在人们身上”，所以仅仅因为你在洛杉矶长大，并不意味着你会更容易接受它，不，我想……我想人们会认为会，而且我认为洛杉矶绝对……不，绝对不是任何东西，我不认为它真的做到了，我的意思是，对我们来说，因为我们没有……我们没有出名的父母，我们的父母没有……但他们都在这个行业，对吧？当然，这是否让它感觉像是你的
pathway into the into any sort of entertainment was was somewhat more sort of natural they validated our dreams and our aspirations but they didn't make them look easy no yeah yeah I think that you know we had like both our parents worked several part-time jobs because they were in and out of work um in terms of acting so if anything it just kind of made us feel like maybe this isn't even ever gonna work for us but you know I think the other thing that was to your point Sean maybe it it doesn't feel weird if someone ends up doing something that wasn't a fantasy or dream of theirs prior but like I wanted to make music from the time I was like 11 to the time I was like 18 19 when anyone actually started to care about the music we made and so those years
进入任何娱乐领域的途径……在某种程度上更自然？他们验证了我们的梦想和抱负，但他们没有让它们看起来很容易，不，是的，是的，我想……你知道，我们有……比如我们的父母都做了几份兼职工作，因为他们进进出出工作，嗯，就表演而言，所以如果有什么的话，它只是让我们觉得也许这甚至永远不会对我们有效，但你知道，我想另一件事是，肖恩，说到你的观点，也许如果有人最终做了一些不是他们之前幻想或梦想的事情，它不会感觉奇怪，但就像我从11岁到18、19岁时一直想做音乐，那时才有人真正开始关心我们制作的音乐，所以那些年
of like I know exactly what I want to do I just have no idea if I'll ever really get a chance to do that right um we're very daunting but it it felt completely unrealistic I used to listen I used to listen to hall of fame by um what's what to go to standing in the hall of fame the world's gonna know your name and I used to just listen to that and be like damn that'd be so crazy like it'd be so crazy if people knew your name and I was like I would listen and be like there's like that doesn't happen though it's just it didn't feel like anything that could ever happen and it still is crazy that it happened does it feel now like you thought it might if you guys were ever able to get as successful as you dreamed of becoming now that you're there does it feel
就像“我确切地知道我想做什么，我只是不知道我是否真的有机会做那个”，对，嗯，非常令人生畏，但它感觉完全不现实，我过去常听……我过去常听《名人堂》，由……嗯，什么……去站在名人堂里，世界会知道你的名字，我过去常听那个，然后想“该死，那会太疯狂了”，就像……如果人们知道你的名字会太疯狂，我当时想……我会听，然后想“就像……那不会发生”，它只是……它感觉不像任何可能发生的事情，而且它发生了仍然很疯狂，它现在感觉像你想象的那样吗？如果你们能够像你们梦想的那样成功，现在你们到了那里，它感觉
like you thought it would be it's way better it's yeah it is better oh that's great that's great at this point what is that what part are you guys really really digging um honestly the parts that I hated three years ago those are the parts that I'm digging now fascinating I don't know really how that works but what are those parts yeah fame in general um I used to just despise it I hated everything about it I hated being recognized I hated not being able to go out I hated you know not being able to post a place because then people would show up at that place wherever it was because they just figure out where it was um I really hated everything about it and I felt stupid because I was like wow I have this thing that like is really cool and people would kill for this and I
像你想象的那样吗？它好多了，它……是的，它更好，哦，那太棒了，那太棒了，在这一点上，你们真正真正喜欢的是什么部分？嗯，老实说，我三年前讨厌的部分，那些是我现在喜欢的，迷人，我真的不知道那是怎么运作的，但那些部分是什么？是的，名声总的来说，嗯，我过去只是鄙视它，我讨厌关于它的一切，我讨厌被认出来，我讨厌不能出去，我讨厌……你知道，不能发布一个地点，因为那样人们就会出现在那个地方，无论它在哪里，因为他们只是弄清楚它在哪里，嗯，我真的讨厌关于它的一切，我觉得自己很蠢，因为我当时想“哇，我有这个东西，它真的很酷，人们会为了这个而杀人”，而我
don't like it at all and you know I was also forgetting that I was really really depressed and that can make you hate almost anything and I don't really know what changed but I fucking love fame I gotta tell you I just I love it is it because you're you're more comfortable with it because you feel more worthy of it or you like what you're doing with it or I I definitely like what I'm doing with it and I feel I feel more confident in it I think that there were some years like the years I'm talking about where I felt like I had to prove myself all the time yeah especially to kids like I grew up with like we had this we you know we have this like tradition of like going to our friend's house for like what fourth of July or whatever and there was just a
一点也不喜欢它，而且你知道，我也忘记了我当时真的真的很沮丧，那会让你讨厌几乎任何东西，我真的不知道是什么改变了，但我该死地喜欢名声，我得告诉你，我只是……我喜欢它，是因为你……你对它更舒服了吗？因为你觉得你更配得上它，或者你喜欢你用它做的事情，还是我……我绝对喜欢我用它做的事情，而且我觉得……我觉得在其中更自信，我想有几年……我谈论的那几年，我觉得我必须一直证明自己，是的，尤其是对像我一起长大的孩子，就像我们有这个……你……我们有这个传统，比如去我们朋友家过……比如独立日什么的，有几年我觉得自己太逊了，因为我……我觉得人们把我当作一个笑话，就像我一辈子认识的人，我觉得每次我去见我认识的人，我都必须……证明我实际上做得很好，但没人相信你，因为你知道，他们……他们不考虑它，因为你从小认识的朋友为什么会突然……当然，我理解那种从对它感到奇怪、不知道如何处理名声，到达到舒适地带的飞跃，我的意思是，在你们出生之前，你们两个在《约书亚树》之后做了那张唱片，他们做了那张流行唱片，这基本上是波诺对名声的某种挣扎，他扮演了一个版本的自己，我想
couple years where I felt so lame because I I felt like people thought of me as like a joke like people that knew me my whole life and I felt like every time I had went and saw people I used to know I had to like prove that I was actually doing pretty well but nobody believes you because you know they they don't think about it because why would your friend that you knew since you were a kid suddenly of course I understand that making that that leap from feeling weird about it and not knowing how to deal with fame and getting to a place of comfort I mean there's a whole before you guys were born you two did that record after Joshua Tree they did that pop record which was basically Bono's whole sort of struggle with fame and he played a version of himself and I think that a
很多那是他试图弄清楚，突然间他是波诺，他正在……他正在世界上做这些伟大的事情，然后你到了一个地方，现在当你和波诺交谈时，他对他是谁非常舒服，是的，是的，因为我刚才想说，说“我该死地喜欢名声”比不这样说要健康得多，而且你处理它的速度比很多人都快，我觉得我可以这么说，因为我曾经讨厌它，所以当我这么说时，我并不是想表现得“我很自大”，而且你知道，因为我有名声，但就像……我想我们应该意识到，或者……你们也是，就像我们应该意识到我们拥有我们可以做的不可思议的事情，是的，你非常漂亮，但看看杰森，这个……大流行对杰森来说就像是……
lot of that was him trying to figure out all of a sudden he's Bono and he's and he's doing these great things in the world and then you get to a place and now when you talk to Bono he's very comfortable with who he is yeah yeah because I was just gonna say it's so much healthier Billy to say I fucking love fame than not and you've processed it quicker than a lot of people do I feel like I can say it because I hated it and so when I say it I'm not trying to be like I'm so cocky and you know because I have fame but it's like I think that we should be aware or the and you guys too like we should be aware that we have an incredible thing that would get to do yeah you're very pretty but look at Jason this the the pandemic is like for Jason it's been
糟糕，因为他讨厌不得不戴口罩，他不想遮住脸，因为他想让人们知道是他，这让他很痛苦，所以我做了一个口罩，上面有我脸的下半部分，来自一张照片，所以我可以戴上口罩，因为他的快乐与……挂钩，是的，所以在五年、10年、15年后，你们还在制作你们喜欢的专辑吗？你们是否看到自己多元化到制作其他年轻艺术家并推出他们？我的意思是，我知道菲尼亚斯，你做了很多那种事，而且你们这么年轻就取得了这么大的成功，你们是否考虑过规划它？“天哪，我们让这东西再持续30年，我们才50岁”，不是每个人都有连环杀手的头脑，杰森，就像你做什么，你在哪里……它……它太白热了
terrible because he hates having to wear a mask he doesn't want to cover his face because he wants people to know it's him and it's killing him so I got a mask made with the bottom half of my face from a photo so I can wear the mask because his happiness is pegged to yeah so in five years and 10 years 15 years you guys still making albums that you love do you do you see yourselves diversifying into producing other young artists and and launching them I mean I know Phineas you do a lot of that and you guys have hit so much success so young do you think about mapping it out like Jesus Christ we keep this thing going for another 30 years we're only 50 not everybody has the mind of a serial killer Jason like what do you do where do you it's it's so white hot
已经，嗯，我尽量不去想它，嗯，我确实有一种强烈的……想要长寿的感觉，是的，我们经常考虑长寿，我想你知道，比莉非常有天赋，对视觉媒体等有很好的眼光，我想我们谈论了很多关于我们最喜欢的艺术，比如几乎没有人有超过五张好专辑，大多数人有一张好专辑，然后没有人有超过五张好专辑，我想……嗯，所以我们有点像是……除了德雷克，除了德雷克，是的，无限供应，是的，他只是继续，当你……你要听音乐时，嗯，那不是你自己的，你现在在听谁？比如你……你……老实说，很多卡朋特乐队，真的，哇，拜托，你不知道，你错过了，你不知道
already um I try not to think about it um I really have a strong feeling of of wanting to be to have longevity yeah we think about longevity a lot I think you know Billy is very multi-talented and this has a great eye for visual media and stuff I think we've talked a lot about how our favorite art like almost no one has like any more than five good albums most people have like one good album and then no one has more than five good albums I think um and so we kind of are like except Drake except Drake yeah unlimited supply yeah he does he just keeps going when you're gonna listen to music uh that's not your own who are you listening to right now like who do you a lot of the carpenters honestly really wow come on you don't know you're missing you don't know
你错过了，他们太棒了，我们喜欢卡朋特乐队，只是不是一直，所以目前我一直在听很多朱莉·伦敦，她不知何故为我营造了气氛，嗯，还有阿洛·帕克斯，刚刚发行了一张专辑，真的很好，是的，但老实说，我一直在……我一直在重播我们未发行的歌曲，因为我真的很喜欢它们，是的，我对它们很满意，它们什么时候从……变成发行，当专辑出来时，嗯，那是什么时候，比莉？我不能告诉任何人，拜托，制造新闻，你们在时间上非常慷慨，不，威尔，那是结束了，你们……我们……我们已经超过了我们承诺的一小时，虽然很有趣，我们深深地、无限地爱你们俩，我爱你们，你们真是太有才华了，真的
you're missing they're amazing we love the carpenters just not all the time so currently I've been listening to a lot of Julie London um she's just been setting the mood for me somehow uh also Arlo Park's just better an album that's really good yeah but honestly I've been just I've just been replaying the unreleased songs we have because I really like them yeah and I'm very happy with them and they're one of those change from on to released when the album comes out well when's that Billy I can't tell anyone come on make news you guys have been super generous with your time no will that's the end of it you guys uh we've we've exceeded our promised hour um been so fun though we love you both deeply immensely I love you guys you guys are such huge talents really
很高兴见到你们，我们是你们的忠实粉丝，所以这非常令人兴奋，即使在这次谈话之后，我也听了《SmartLess》，我和我女朋友一直都在听，拜托，而且因为我觉得我们在这一集中网络欺凌了肖恩，我想用我最喜欢的肖恩说过的话来结束，那就是在广告阅读期间，有一次杰森你走“是的，我刚吃了一个能量棒”，肖恩说“哦，那什么时候起作用？”，我觉得那是一个火花，那让我……嚎叫大笑，那真的杀了我，有很多残酷的东西，在这个Zoom聊天中被抛来抛去，嗯，这是残酷的茶，而且……那是你的……教育，再次抬头，所以谢谢你们，你们是最棒的
exciting to meet you guys we're big fans of you guys so this is very exciting even after this talk I listened to smartlist my girlfriend and I both listen to it all the time come on and because I feel like we've cyber bullied Sean on this episode I wanted to close with my favorite thing Sean's ever said which is during like an ad read at one point Jason you go yeah I just had an energy bar and Sean goes oh when does that kick in I thought that was a fire that that made me like howl laugh that really killed me there's a lot of cruelness it gets thrown around this this zoom chat well it's cruel tea and uh there's your uh education mirroring it's ugly head again so thank you you guys you're the best
谢谢，见到你对我来说真的很兴奋，对我们所有人来说，我只是……真的、真的、真的、老实说，非常感谢你们，谢谢你们做这件事，继续成功，快点把那张专辑推出来，请，我们想要更多的音乐，我们会尝试，不能，我们爱你们，谢谢你们有这样的款待，伙计们，谢谢，哇，现在听着，你知道我是一个父母，我希望我的孩子长大后像那样，而且他们仍然相处得很好，并且他们很有成效，我们之前谈过这个吗？你们会……你们会家庭教育吗？或者你们……或者我……我有我自己的伤疤，比如作为一个孩子没有参与常规学校，并且在某种程度上失去了社交结构，我不会，但这只是因为我自己的包袱，我……你知道，我相信它很棒，我相信
thank you it was so exciting to meet you for me truly and for all of us I just uh really really truly honestly a huge thank you guys thank you for doing this continued success push that album out soon please we'd like more music we'll try can't we love you guys thanks for having such a treat by you guys thank you wow now listen you know I'm a parent I hope my kids grow up to be like that and that they still get along and they're productive did we talk about this before would you guys ever home school or did you or I I've got my own scars of sort of like not being involved in a regular school as a as a kid and sort of losing out on the social structure of of at all that I would not but that's only because of my own baggage I'm you know I'm sure it's great I'm sure
谢谢，对我来说，能见到你们真是太令人兴奋了，对我们所有人来说也是。我真的，非常非常真诚地，非常感谢你们。谢谢你们做这一切。祝你们继续取得成功，请尽快推出那张专辑，我们想要更多的音乐。我们会努力的。不能吗？我们爱你们。谢谢你们的邀请，和你们在一起真是太棒了。谢谢。哇，听着，你知道我是一个家长，我希望我的孩子们长大后能像你们一样，而且他们还能相处融洽，并且富有成效。我们之前谈过这个吗？你们会考虑在家教育孩子吗？或者你们曾经这样做过吗？我小时候因为没有上正规学校，在某种程度上失去了一些社交结构，这给我留下了一些心理阴影。我不会那样做，但这只是因为我自己的心理负担。我知道这肯定很好，我确定。
it's fine but right that's interesting well would you ever home school arch-enable um no this is the closest we've come to it obviously during the pandemic and so it's not going well well no I mean it's going as well as it's going for everybody it's it's very very trying and I think that what we're missing is that socialization and you know you can't stress enough how important that is I think for my good Billy and Phineas they seem but they've turned out great I know I know it's like but like where do they go to like how would you meet a boyfriend or a girlfriend if you're home school I don't know and they're like they're like four years he's like four years older than her too or something right so like they weren't it like my kids it's different for them even during this
没关系，不过这很有趣。你会考虑让阿奇在家自学吗？嗯，不，这显然是我们疫情期间最接近在家自学的状态了，所以情况不太好。好吧，不，我的意思是，这对每个人来说都一样，非常非常吃力。我认为我们缺失的是社交，你知道，无论怎么强调社交的重要性都不为过。我觉得对于我的好孩子比利和菲尼亚斯来说，他们看起来……但他们表现得很好。我知道，我知道，就像……但他们去哪里呢？如果你在家自学，你怎么认识男朋友或女朋友？我不知道。而且他们相差四岁，他比她大四岁左右，对吧？所以他们不像我的孩子，即使在疫情期间，对他们来说情况也不同，
pandemic because they're so close in age um you know a lot of their friends are very similar and you know of similar age above it must be tough when you're you're a younger sister and your your brother's four years older than you yeah that's a huge you know you're you're a freshman while your brother's a senior in high school yeah and that's that's a big how do you do school together yeah yeah I've always wondered that I just I think it's fascinating like I read this about Billie Eilish and her parents and that they just constantly reinforced creativity around the house so you couldn't get that at a public school I mean yes you can in certain you know programs and stuff but it's constant at home it's always constant I'm sure they're reaping the benefits of having
因为他们的年龄非常接近，嗯，你知道，他们的很多朋友都很相似，而且年龄也相仿。当你有一个比你大四岁的哥哥时，这一定很艰难。是的，那差距很大，你知道，你上高一的时候，你哥哥已经是高三学生了。是的，那差距很大，你们怎么一起上学呢？是的，我一直很好奇。我只是觉得这很迷人，就像我读到关于碧梨和她父母的事，他们在家里不断地强化创造力，所以你在公立学校是得不到这种环境的。我的意思是，在某些项目中是可以的，但在家里是持续不断的，总是持续不断的。我相信他们正在享受拥有
such a stable upbringing and such a close and healthy relationship with their parents that they're they're in this this you know this cauldron of anxiety or temptation or um you know that they've got that solid home base is probably really helpful for them if I had kids I if and I saw that as an example but yeah maybe I should homeschool but we do have like we have the three of us have mutual friends I can think of a couple people who have who homeschool their kids and it really works out for them yeah and it's and it so happens that because of their because of how much they're in the public eye and how well known they are that it really works I mean apart from the fact that it works for them in terms of travel and stuff because of work but also because of that level of you
如此稳定的成长环境，以及与父母如此亲密和健康的关系所带来的好处。他们处于这种焦虑或诱惑的熔炉中，拥有坚实的家庭基础可能对他们非常有帮助。如果我有孩子，如果我看到这个例子，也许我应该在家自学。但我们确实有共同的朋友，我能想到几个人，他们让孩子在家自学，这对他们来说真的很有效。是的，而且恰好因为他们如此受公众关注，如此出名，所以这真的很有效。我的意思是，除了因为工作需要旅行等原因，这对他们很有效之外，还因为那种程度的你
know notoriety and now because of COVID everybody's homeschooling yeah and so like first of all it's served them well during COVID because they're like we know what we're doing in this environment yeah the last year and a half has been good exactly and uh but also you know they've figured it out Jason have did you know Billy to bring her on the show and by the way great guests thank you very much unbelievable guests uh I met them at Kimmel show um and they were super complimentary about um Arrested Development and uh they liked Ozark and um so Sean Arrested Development is a TV show Jason let me finish let me finish but what they really loved was Cheers so Sean you um you uh yeah okay great and how long Sean were you on Cheers so you know I was a first day player
知道，名气。现在因为新冠疫情，每个人都在家自学。是的，所以首先，这在疫情期间对他们很有帮助，因为他们会说，我们知道在这种环境下该怎么做。是的，过去一年半过得不错。没错，而且，你知道，他们已经搞定了。杰森，你认识碧梨吗？能请她上节目吗？顺便说一句，很棒的嘉宾，非常感谢，令人难以置信的嘉宾。我在吉米鸡毛秀上见过他们，他们对《发展受阻》非常赞赏，他们也喜欢《黑钱胜地》，所以肖恩，《发展受阻》是一部电视剧。杰森，让我说完，让我说完。但他们真正喜欢的是《欢乐酒店》。所以肖恩，你……嗯，是的，好吧，太棒了。肖恩，你在《欢乐酒店》待了多久？所以我知道，我是一个第一天的演员，
yeah and then I did a really good job expanded them to the to the postman yeah to the oh you did the post guy oh man I love that how are you ah normie how are you normie no no anyway Billy and Finn our heart were fantastic weren't they yeah they're uh they're an inspiration to every brother and sister out there There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，然后我做得非常好，把角色扩展到了邮递员。哦，你演了邮递员？天哪，我喜欢那个。你好啊，诺米，你好吗，诺米？不，不，总之，碧梨和芬恩真是太棒了，不是吗？是的，他们是所有兄弟姐妹的榜样。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。